alors on est sur le stand de roborock on
va se prendre quelques minutes le temps
que tout le monde arrive et puis moi que
je me connecte également avec ma
tablette pour venir suivre ce live je
suis très heureux de le faire avec vous
aujourd'hui alors regardez je suis là on
s'installe tac on est connecté on est en
direct et puis surtout on se fait un
live qui va être super cool directement
ici sur le stand de roborock au CES à
Las Vegas c'est pas rien de faire ça ici
donc croyez-moi ça va vraiment vraiment
envoyer du bois hop là je me connecte je
vous rejoins je me mets sur ma chaîne
comme ça je vais suivre le live avec
vous je vais avoir toutes les questions
qui vont arriver hop là je vois que vous
êtes là vous êtes là et le monsieur gros
tout le monde première question est-ce
que vous m'entendez bien est-ce que tout
va bien est-ce que tout est ok marqué le
moi dans le chat comme ça nous on va
suivre ça en direct et puis moi je me
vois en même temps voyez j'ai mon retour
moniteur comme ça c'est extrêmement
pratique donc dites-moi voilà je vois
que vous arrivez tranquillement salut
coucou vous m'entendez bien est-ce que
le son est de bonne qualité parce que
c'est une première de faire un live
directement comme ça au smartphone
depuis le salon le CES à Las Vegas alors
pour les 18h30 et quelques nous il est
9h30 du matin on est déjà réveillé
depuis quelques heures et soir préparer
ce live mais on est là tout est ok 5 sur
5 parfait le son est bon ok alors je
vous explique ce qui va se passer ici au
CES robot vient présenter plein de
nouveaux produits vous savez moi j'adore
roborock j'adore leurs produits je
trouve hyper cool ils sont hyper
fonctionnels et pour la maison connectée
c'est génial vous avez une application
bref donc la robe rock nous présente
plein de nouveaux produits on est sur
leur stand qui est juste énorme ici au
CES à Las Vegas on a une petite heure à
passer ensemble voir plus si affinité et
surtout il y a un truc très cool c'est
qu'il va y avoir un concours un concours
avec des cadeaux à gagner ouais nous
elle est passée mais je me déguise un
peu en père Noël et je vais vous offrir
des cadeaux donc ça c'est cool ce qu'on
va gagner c'est pas le dernier
aspirateur c'est un modèle juste d'avant
très haut de gamme c'est le S7 max V
plus alors on donnera on fera le
concours à la fin du live j'annoncerai
les gagnants à la fin du live donc
suivez bien le live il y aura deux
robots à gagner et les questions vont
porter sur le live donc restez bien avec
nous restez connectés pour tout suivre
et tout ça va je vous montrer rapidement
un peu un petit tour du stand avant
qu'on commence venez voir ici donc là on
va avoir différents produits qu'on va
venir vous montrer déjà un peu de monde
qui arrive là sur le sur le stand on va
venir montrer le S8 qui est ici S8 et
suite plus donc ça c'est une des
nouveautés nouveautés super
intéressantes ça c'est le S8 le S8 plus
et juste à côté et puis surtout le
modèle qui va juste être complètement
dingue ça va être celui-là ça va être le
S8 pro ultra le S8 pro ultra de la même
manière je vais tout vous expliquer vous
le montrer parce que c'est vraiment un
produit qui est juste topissime et puis
ensuite je vais vous montrer un autre
robot aspirateur qui est très cool c'est
le diable pro alors on connaît le diable
qui a été présenté l'année dernière mais
là on passe sur un niveau supérieur
application connectée intelligent bref
ça va vous solutionner beaucoup de
problèmes pour la maison donc ça c'est
aussi vachement bien et puis pendant ce
live on va également parler techno parce
qu'on est une chaîne de tech et bien
évidemment on l'attaque et on a une que
ce soit compréhensible et qu'on
comprenne comment marcher techno donc
ici les robots sont ouverts on vous
montre toutes les techno je vais tout
vous expliquer de l'aspiration de
l'autonettoyage de la vibration bref on
va voir énormément de choses donc voilà
pour ce live qui débute tranquillou on
s'installe en toute dernière chose dont
une chronologie pour que vous voyez bien
qui est roborock on va passer à
l'arrière du stand elle suivez moi comme
ça vous êtes dans les coulisses vous
voyez tout et bien en fait roborock
c'est une boîte là depuis des lustres et
c'est une boîte que j'adore vraiment
personnellement parce que leurs produits
sont hyper efficaces et marche bien on
va parler ici voyons une petite frise
chronologique 2008 le S5 c'est une
grande histoire roborock 2019 le S5 max
on regarde 2020 ça je vous en ai déjà
parlé également je vous ai présenté
beaucoup de produits le S5 j'avais déjà
montré on est arrivé ensuite sur les S7
S7 plus et puis 2022 voyez on se
rapproche le S7 max V ultra absolument
incroyable et puis après dans les
cusserics sont plus milieu de gamme sur
roborock et la série S qui est le très
haut de gamme donc on y va on part je
vois tout le monde est là à tout le
monde est installé je vous vois dans le
chat salut salut hop là regardez venez
on va aller parler des S7 8 vous allez
voir toutes les questions très très cool
je regarde un peu vos messages je suis
content de vous voir coucou coucou c'est
pas super net c'est peut-être ta
connexion
normalement si ça se réalise-moi si
jamais il y a un truc qui va pas le son
l'image comme ça on avance ensemble mais
ça c'est chouette alors venez mes petits
lapins on va venir se positionner ici on
va commencer à regarder un peu ces
différents aspirateurs beau alors on est
sur un salon il y a du monde donc on va
essayer tous de se payer un peu notre
chemin on va venir regarder ce qui se
passe peut-être au niveau du modèle
ultra qui est là regardez venez là en
fait vous avez une vraie différence
entre ces deux produits entre la partie
est-ce que live thank you on a une
différence entre deux produits au niveau
des S8 S8 S8 plus en fait c'est le même
robot va y avoir une différence qui va
se faire au niveau du système de charge
et au niveau de système pour gérer vos
petits déchets vos cochonneries et on a
le modèle le plus haut de gamme c'est le
S8 pro ultra le robot est différent les
techno sont encore supérieures et vous
avez tout un système pour venir
récupérer de l'eau salée injecter de
l'eau propre en fait je vous montre très
d'autres tâches donc ça c'est très cool
et c'est un truc que j'aime bien et
l'autre truc qui me plaît beaucoup c'est
qu'ils ont cette technologie que vous
allez avoir à l'avant avec un leader
c'est un laser en fait qui va venir
reconnaître les objets je vais vous
montrer dans quelques instants donc ça
c'est ce que vous avez sur les S8 et S8
plus la grosse différence que vous avez
entre les deux modèles c'est sur le S8
vous voyez vous avez juste une petite
station de recharge donc il est posé
comme ça à la maison il va venir se
recharger tandis que quand vous arrivez
sur le S8 plus là vous avez la magie là
dessous vous avez un petit sac donc le
truc qui est cool c'est que ça vous
permet de garder les déchets un peu plus
un peu plus longtemps il est plus
autonome en fait parce que lui il va
venir récupérer les déchets qu'elle a il
va les remonter là et vous vous venez
changer votre sac de temps en temps et
vous n'êtes pas tout le temps après
chaque utilisation comme sur le S8 à
devoir vider toute la partie du bas donc
ça c'est pas un
un truc qu'on connaissait déjà l'année
dernière ça c'est vachement bien grosse
nouveauté et que je trouve super
intéressantes ici c'est que on vient
augmenter la puissance d'aspiration on
passe ici sur
Pascal de puissance d'aspiration alors
je sais pas si les chiffres ça vous
parle et croyez moi c'est un truc qui
est absolument dingue donc ça envoie du
bois d'une façon absolument incroyable
alors il y a un autre truc je vais vous
montrer sur le pro du train on se parle
ici du plus haut de gamme chez roborock
en 2023 le prout un truc qui est très
cool alors au-delà je vais commencer par
l'aspirateur pour vous montrer vraiment
la différence que vous la compreniez
parce que ça l'aspirateur du pro ultra
et l'aspirateur du S8 plus en fait sont
deux robots différents il y a deux
technologies qui sont réellement c'est à
dire que en fait à l'arrière vous avez
le même techno au niveau de la partie
qui va venir récupérer vos déchets la
petite brossette là qui ramène tout
l'intérieur et lui après il fait le taf
mais lui il a une techno différente que
l'autre n'a pas c'est à dire que cette
partie là elle peut venir remonter
c'est-à-dire que si vous voulez juste
passer la serpillière sans aspirer lui
remonte il va pas frotter il va pas
s'user donc ça c'est pas une techno
propriétaire qu'on retrouve uniquement
sur le S8 pro ultra qui marche très bien
et autre truc où il y a une vraie
différence entre le S8 pro ultra et les
S8 et les S8 plus c'est qu'en fait ici
là vous voyez cette partie là elle va
vibrer elle vibrer pourquoi parce que
lorsque vous passez à la serpillière ça
vient vibrer et ça va permettre
effectivement et bien de venir nettoyer
ici vous avez un double moteur sur le
pro ultra tandis que si vous prenez
l'autre aspi ici vous avez un simple
moteur vous avez pas hop là regardez on
fait comme à la maison on enlève tout
vous voyez ici vous avez un simple grand
moteur donc il y a vraiment cette
différence un moteur de moteur c'est là
où se fait toute la différence entre les
S8 S8 plus et le pro ultra alors pour
autant il y a quand même plein de
nouvelles innovations dans les suit plus
par rapport au modèle qu'on avait
l'année précédente donc ça c'est cool
mais voilà vous allez en faire plus avec
le pro ultra alors forcément le tarif ça
fait cher on s'en doutera mais ça
fonctionne bien alors autre truc
intéressant et qu'on a vu arriver dans
les robots-aspirateurs il y a quelques
temps c'est à dire qu'en fait
ils sont là pour vous solutionner la vie
on n'est pas envie de s'embêter on n'a
pas envie de se prendre la tête avec
donc qu'est-ce qu'ils vont venir faire
et ben ils sont totalement autonomes
donc vous pouvez faire des choses on
peut dire programmer des routines
directement avec votre robot aspirateur
c'est-à-dire vous lui dites bah tiens le
lundi tu vas dans quelle pièce tu fais
ça et lui il va faire le taf tout seul
et vous vous posez pas de question vous
prenez pas la tête surtout avec celui-là
parce que autant si vous prenez le S8
vous allez devoir rajouter de l'eau vous
allez devoir ensuite les pâtes
récupération d'eau salles donc vous
allez voir rajouter de l'eau vous allez
devoir enlever les couches de riz lui il
fait le taf tout seul et il le fait bien
donc ça c'est chouette ça veut dire que
en fait vous allez faire juste une chose
de temps en temps vous allez venir
remplir votre réservoir d'eau propre et
lui il va venir le mettre directement
dans le robot lorsqu'il le passe donc ça
c'est cool et même le truc qui est très
cool c'est que lorsqu'il est en train de
le passer et bien il va se recharger
durant le lavage donc ça c'est vachement
malin et qu'est-ce qu'il fait il remplit
le réservoir d'eau avec de l'eau propre
mais juste avant il enlève l'eau sale
c'est-à-dire qu'une fois que vous avez
un qui est tout cracra sur le sol bah
lui il la met là et vous êtes tranquille
donc ça vous me le vider de temps en
temps l'autre vous me le remplissez il y
a un autre truc qui est très cool c'est
que vous avez juste ici pareil un sac au
niveau de l'aspiration donc vous venez
changer votre sac de temps en temps avec
vos cochonneries qui sont là et vous
êtes peinard donc ça vous permet
réellement d'être totalement tranquille
totalement indépendant à la maison et
d'être vraiment payant donc ça pour moi
c'est un truc qui est extrêmement
important parce que des tonnes
d'aspirateur le roborock j'en ai vu
plusieurs dans le temps j'en ai essayé
plein et je trouve que le fait d'avoir
un produit comme ça qui est hyper
complet alors fatalement beaucoup plus
cher soyons clairs mais je trouve ça
vachement bien parce que ça vous évite
de venir vous poser la question tiens
est-ce que j'ai de l'eau tiens est-ce
que le truc et des salles ah tiens ce
qui va vraiment passer ce qui va marcher
donc ça ça bosse tout seul et je trouve
ça juste hyper hyper cool mes petits
lapins donc je suis content je voulais
le partager avec vous alors il y a
d'autres choses aussi avec ce produit à
venir reconnaître c'est que je vous le
dis il y a de la reconnaissance 3D vous
pouvez venir éviter les objets
d'ailleurs regardez je vous montre ça se
passe par ici
en fait il est intelligent il est malin
et venez voir ça se passe par ici il va
venir reconnaître les objets à la maison
donc là il est en train de faire la démo
vous avez une paire de chaussures il la
voit il la détecte alors ici il y a pas
de caméra c'est à dire que vous avez pas
une caméra qui va venir filmer chez vous
vous allez pas avoir la photo des objets
il va juste venir scanner et grâce au
laser au lidar il va savoir quel objet
c'est vous aurez l'icône directement sur
votre application ça c'est aussi un
autre point l'application je vous en
parlerai tout à l'heure mais là voyez là
vous avez les chaussures là vous avez un
câble qui est posé et lui il va faire le
taf tout seul directement donc je trouve
ça une fois de plus vraiment pratique et
puis de la même manière il va venir
cartographier vos pièces donc vous avez
vraiment une cartographie de votre
maison vous savez dans quelle pièce il
va venir se positionner vous pouvez
l'envoyer dire machin va me faire que la
cuisine tout de suite tu veux bah tiens
tu vas me faire la chambre passer deux
fois dans la chambre parce que c'est un
peu plus sale donc on peut vraiment
venir programmer ça c'est un truc qui
existait déjà chez roborock avant mais
c'est un des gros points forts qu'on
doit retrouver chez rebreux parce que
c'est extrêmement pratique et une fois
de plus vous je sais pas vous avez un
verre vous le faites tomber dans la
cuisine chez nous ou une cochonnerie lui
il vient il vient de nettoyer tu vas là
et de la même année on a ce qu'on
appelle des nogozone moi par exemple
chez moi mon fils il veut pas que le
robot aille dans sa chambre et pour
cause il y a plein de jeux il y a plein
de jouets et s'il y va faire la gueule
il va lui bouger tous les Lego bref
catastrophe donc je mets une barrière
devant sa porte il n'y va pas par contre
c'est moi qui fait le boulot bon ma
femme on est comme ça et comme ça c'est
pratique donc on peut venir dire bah
tiens tu vas nettoyer que cette zone là
tu ne vas pas dans cette zone bref c'est
très complet très pratique pour la
maison ça c'est vraiment un truc que
j'aime et je trouve ça vraiment
vachement bien alors j'ai quelques infos
à venir vous donner également avec le S8
ultra vous avez cette semaine de
tranquillité au niveau de votre
réservoir d'eau et au niveau de votre
sac d'aspiration qu'on vient vider donc
ça c'est vachement bien puis il a une
autre technologie une erreur je vais
vous montrer et on va regarder ça
également c'est à dire que c'est un
petit pour y aller au qui tient la
caméra léo je veux dire il fait un petit
marathon il regarde il va éviter de
trébucher aussi parce que sinon ça va
être la cata en fait si vous regardez
bien en
en fait tout en bas il y a toute une
partie où votre robot il va venir s'auto
nettoyer ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que sur toute la partie du bas et je
vous le montrerai à côté technique et
bien lorsque il a fini son boulot il va
venir se poser et votre partie alors
c'est pas le même et c'est pour vous
compreniez un peu le système c'est à
dire que toute cette partie là elle va
venir se sécher alors pas sur le S8 mais
sur le S8 pro ultra ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que vous êtes sûr que votre on
peut pas dire serpillière mais
équivalent elle est sèche elle est clean
ils le font avec de l'air chaud ça va
éviter la prolifération de bactéries ça
va éviter également les odeurs éviter
les mauvaises odeurs à la maison donc ça
c'est pareil c'est un truc que je trouve
extrêmement extrêmement pratique
d'autant plus qu'ici il y a eu un truc
qui a été amélioré au niveau du dock
vous avez une charge qui est quand même
30% plus rapide donc ça c'est quand même
extrêmement cool je donne un peu des
infos comme ça pas le mail pour vous
voyez vraiment comment ça se passe
tac tac je crois que je vous ai à peu
près à peu près tout dit à savoir que
vous la partie vibration que vous avez
sur le S8 pro ultra vous allez monter
beaucoup plus vous avez 3000 vibrations
par minute autant vous dire que lorsque
ça nettoie sur le sol je vais vous
montrer la partie technique tout à
l'heure vous allez voir ça on voit du
bois et ça se moque pas de vous et puis
il y a un truc qui est vraiment bluffant
si vous le disais c'est la puissance
d'aspiration c'est par ici de 6000
Pascal sur le S7 c'est-à-dire remonte
sur la génération d'avant on était à
2500 Pascal donc ils ont fait plus que
doubler c'est absolument dingue et sur
le S7 max V ultra le nom est un petit
peu long on était à 5100 Pascal donc ils
vont toujours plus haut pour venir
choper plus de cochonneries notamment
sur les tapis des fois qui sont un peu
compliqué comme ça vous êtes sûr que
vous en ramassez un petit peu plus donc
ça c'est quand même super cool alors on
se parle d'un produit qui sera
disponible ceci en tout cas les la gamme
S8 à partir de mars avril
2023 et à partir de 699 euros voilà
voilà un peu pour pour ces produits je
crois que on a vu à peu près tout ce
qu'on avait à voir ici là dessus je
regarde un petit peu vos messages j'en
profite 6000 Pascal coule le live sur un
robot rock je regarde un peu vos
messages quel prix donc ça je voulais
dire tu assures monsieur gros medinico
merci beaucoup Nico n'oubliez pas les
pouces si vous appréciez cela les amis
bah c'est gentil merci nettoie technique
si vous aimez effectivement avec urgent
ça vous abonner
également de la même manière je kiffe
ton live c'est moi qui te kiffe c'est
très cool de pouvoir vous lire vous
savez c'est chouette parce que quand on
vient ici au CES Las Vegas
c'est pas de live on enregistre plein de
choses et on enregistrer plein de trucs
on va vous diffuser mais le fait de
pouvoir interagir comme ça avec vous on
va faire davantage parce que je sois
très chouette il y a que roborock non
mais en tout cas ici oui c'est ce que je
préfère j'ai mal à la tête prends un
doliprane ça ira mieux autonomie en
fonction alors en fait la question
d'autonomie aujourd'hui on vient plus la
poser je vais te dire pourquoi parce
qu'en fait on garde ça pour la c'est
parti de cette question constant à la
fin en fait ton robot il vient il se
recharge et après il continue son
programme jusqu'à ce qu'il ait fini donc
en fait l'idée c'est de venir le
programmer lorsqu'on est pas à la maison
lorsqu'on va bosser ou on sait qu'on est
pas voilà comme ça lui qui soit parti
sur Charger ou pas pour nous ça change
absolument rien bon ce truc là est
vachement cool donc c'est vraiment un
truc que j'aime et que j'apprécie
particulièrement ici chez roborock donc
voilà pour toute cette partie au niveau
des S8 S8 S8 plus S8 pro ultra alors je
vous le redis si vous étiez pas là au
début du live on va vous faire gagner
des aspirateurs robots de roborock j'ai
deux robot rock S7 max V+ à venir vous
faire gagner les questions vont poser
sur le contenu du live donc écoutez bien
vous allez voir les produits qu'on fait
gagner il est juste magnifique c'est pas
on dirait dans le haut de gamme
génération précédente mais très haut de
gamme sur roborock c'est un produit qui
est juste hyper canon donc écoutez bien
le live soyez attentifs à la fin du live
je vais vous dire allez j'ai à peu près
chronométré je pense que vers allez
19h15 19h20 on va faire le concours tous
ensemble et puis juste avant dans une
session de questions-répon donc si vous
avez des questions sur un des produits
que je vous présente là on va pouvoir le
regarder ensemble vous répondre
directement ça c'est très chouette donc
voilà pour ces produits on regarde bien
la différence entre d'un côté le S8 vous
avez un aspirateur qui est juste top
vous avez toute la recharge vous avez
une petite hop là une partie avec votre
réservoir d'eau qui est là vous avez
votre petit filtre qui va situer à
l'intérieur et ici il faut venir vider
vous le bac lorsqu'il a bossé lui il se
recharge ici mais pas plus pas moins il
fait le boulot il le fait bien sa
dernière génération il vient toucher les
objets comme ça vous êtes sûr qu'à la
maison il va rien abîmer il passe
partout mais ça force même des coins ça
c'est vraiment génial et c'est très
bluffant dont on va fonctionner on est
arrivé ensuite pour le petit réc sur le
S8 plus c'est le même robot exactement
le même vous voyez il existe en blanc il
existe en noir mais c'est exactement le
même robot à l'intérieur la différence
c'est que vous avez ici votre sac on va
venir récupérer les cochonneries et ça
c'est vachement cool et puis ensuite
vous avez le dernier le plus haut de
gamme le robot est différent parce que
même si la base reste la même la techno
à l'intérieur est différente on a le
système et je vous le redis une fois de
plus pour ceux qui étaient pas là tout à
l'heure quand vous voulez venir aspirer
que les petites brosses elles tournent
ça peut venir remonter si vous souhaitez
uniquement venir passer la serpillière
et tout en sachant et surtout les
modèles c'est à dire que la partie
serpillière elle peut venir remonter
lorsque vous arrivez notamment sur un
tapis on va pas passer à la serpillière
sur un tapis donc ça vient remonter et
ça c'est extrêmement pratique voilà et
ici vous avez deux moteurs pour la
vibration contre un seul moteur sur le
S8 et le S8 plus et puis surtout ce qui
fait tout le bénéfice du modèle S8 pro
ultra c'est le fait que vous avez un
réservoir d'eau propre en réservoir
d'eau salles vous avez votre réservoir à
votre sac d'aspiration qui est situé
juste là et lorsqu'il a fini le boulot
et bien il vient se nettoyer directement
ici
bien tout sécher il vient sécher à la
fois votre serpillière et bien tout
nettoyer vous êtes sur un aspirateur qui
est toujours propre et ça c'est cool
parce que aspirateur ça vient nettoyer
on veut qu'il soit propre et ça c'est
pratique donc maintenant on va passer
sur un autre produit que je viens de
lancer roborock c'est le diable pro on a
déjà eu le diable l'année dernière je
sais pas si vous le connaissiez là on
arrive sur un modèle qui va aller encore
un peu plus loin viens voir c'est juste
derrière ici le store est grand il y a
du monde qui arrive donc ça se passe
juste ici regardez vous avez le diad pro
alors regardez on va aller voir ici le
diapro il ressemble à ça le diable pro
c'est quoi c'est un aspirateur qu'on va
venir prendre à la main et que vous
allez vous balader il fait pas le boulot
tout seul enfin il fait le boulot tout
seul mais il faut le diriger à la
différence de robot qui eux vont faire
le job vous n'êtes pas là il travaille
là il faut que vous soyez là il faut que
vous ayez la poignée dessus alors ce qui
est très intéressant avec ce robot
est-ce qu'il faut vraiment venir voir
c'est qu'en fait vous avez une solution
sans fil donc pas besoin d'avoir un
câble vous le recharger et vous avez une
grosse autonomie on se parle ici de 40
minutes d'autonomie et après vous le
recharger donc il fait le taf tout seul
vous le posez sur ce sur sa base le truc
qui est aussi intéressant c'est qu'il
fait un nettoyage à la fois nettoyage
sec donc ramasser les cochonneries par
terre mais également nettoyage humide
dont vous pouvez venir passer pour
mettre de l'eau avec un détergent qui à
l'intérieur et je vais vous montrer ça
c'est très chouette il y a toute une
partie aussi ça c'est super bien d'auto
nettoyage sur son doc c'est à dire que
il est ici sur sa base de recharge donc
là il vient se recharger et en même
temps et je vais vous montrer la techno
dans quelques instants lui il va venir
se nettoyer avec une rotation au niveau
des brosses et je vous en parle dans
quelques instants vous avez l'auto
nettoyage du bac vous avez aussi une
très grosse puissance d'aspiration
là-bas on se parlait de 6000 Pascal
on se parle de
17000 Pascal c'est un truc de dingue
donc là vous êtes sûr que tout va être
ramassé ça c'est vachement bien et puis
vous avez un système qui est vraiment
intéressant avec deux rouleaux en fait
vous avez un rouleau sur toute la
longueur et vous êtes deux rouleaux
arrière qui vont trouver dans la
direction opposées pour être sûr tout
ramasser pour bien nettoyer vous avez
aussi le dire texte Smart sensor qui
détecte la concentration de saletés sur
les rouleaux et qui va adapter la
puissance de nettoyage et le débit d'eau
également donc ça c'est chouette donc si
vous avez besoin qui sont plus sales lui
il va le voir et il va y aller au tacos
mon petit lapin ça c'est bien et puis on
a également toute l'application ça c'est
très cool parce que on l'avait pas avant
là on a accès à l'application pour venir
moduler des choses dessus et puis vous
avez aussi une distribution automatique
de la solution de nettoyage donc on va
vous faire une petite démo caméra
donc regardez on va vous montrer on va
venir
[Musique]
comme ça
voilà et puis du jus d'orange voilà
comme ça je vais vous dire à la maison
ça envoie du bois on est peinard
donc ça c'est très cool on prend
l'aspirateur
oh regardez on met le pied on le penche
et il se lance directement et on vient
donc là on est sur un nettoyage humide
on vient on passe dessus avant arrière
ça vous nettoie tout c'est extrêmement
simple là vous preniez la tronche
franchement avant lorsque vous en étiez
partout ici le boulot se fait très
simplement
et la regarder on a la solution enfin ça
va c'est le détergent qui est ici qui
vient se mettre dans le réservoir juste
à l'avant ici et vous voyez vous allez
brosse en bas qui vont tourner en sens
opposé alors je vous montrerai que tout
à l'heure le côté technique mais voyez
la brosse elle est située là on
regardera tout à l'heure le détail vous
le verrez donc ça c'est quand même
vachement bien là vous avez toute votre
saleté qui est ici qui passe dans un
film donc là vous avez votre solution
sale et aussi vous avez le réservoir
d'eau propre donc là quand même vous
êtes vraiment vraiment peinard et le
truc est très très cool si je peux laver
mon chien avec j'achète je ne conseille
pas pour ton chien will Gex je pense pas
que ce soit forcément la bonne idée
regardez l'application on vous montre un
peu comment ça fonctionne l'application
donc là on est tout de suite sur le mode
automatique avec un débit d'eau moyen on
a une puissance d'aspiration là et on
peut venir choisir ok donc
ça s'appelle voilà le diable pro il est
là on se reconnecte assez Bonaldi vous
savez il y a toujours un moment où
marcher quand vous êtes en live
directement donc vous avez l'application
ça c'est des grosses fonctionnalités
c'est que vous pouvez venir régler votre
débit d'eau votre puissance d'aspiration
directement dans l'application en fait
c'est pas juste un robot vous venez vous
lancer vous partez comme ça vous pouvez
venir paramétrer les choses ça vous
permet d'avoir un truc qui est beaucoup
plus complet et je trouve ça vachement
chouette donc ça c'est super cool
regardez ça se passe juste là donc là
vous réglez votre puissance d'aspiration
donc là on est en mode Turbo on peut
venir se mettre ensuite en mode
équilibré et là en mode délicat ça va
venir moduler aussi le son parce que
plus vous allez descendre et moins il
fera de bruit alors là on va pas trop
s'en rendre compte sur le salon mais ça
évite d'avoir trop de bruit si on veut
pas franchement si vous voulez le truc
qui va le plus vite nous on était ici en
mode Turbo s'envoi du bois et pareil au
niveau de l'eau on va injecter plus ou
moins d'eau niveau moyen là on va
envoyer vachement de flotte autant vous
dire que si c'est un peu sec c'est ce
qu'il faudrait le mieux et puis si un
niveau d'eau un peu plus faible
également et puis on peut venir
également paramétrer la vitesse du là on
est sur un rouleau qui va être lent et
puis on peut aller beaucoup plus vite
également donc ce qui est très chouette
avec ça c'est qu'on vient réellement
paramétrer comme on le souhaite en
fonction des tâches qu'on va retrouver
si c'est du liquide si c'est du solide
tout va se régler comme ça ici donc ça
vachement cool vachement bien et puis
pour l'éteindre voilà on repose le pied
on le met à l'avant il s'arrête ça c'est
chouette regardez hop là on pose le pied
on le tire il se lance il reconnaît
directement vous nettoyez là on va
injecter de l'eau directement on le
repose comme ça et il s'arrête tout
simplement et ensuite on vient le
reposer ici dans sa zone de recharge
alors vous le voyez pas mais je vais
vous le montrer tout à l'heure toute la
partie en bas vous allez avoir tout un
séchage qui va venir s'opérer
directement donc là vous voyez il vient
sécher avec la rotation des brosses
celle-là et l'autre ça permet de venir
la sécher et comme sur les S8 en fait
sur le S8 ultra 8 Pro ultra ça permet
d'éviter les moisissures éviter les
odeurs ça vient se nettoyer alors ça va
durer un petit peu mais comme ça vous
avez quelque chose qui est toujours
propre toujours prêt à être utilisé et
sans que ça sente l'humidité c'est
croyez-moi quand même c'est pareil donc
ça c'est vraiment chouette
ah oui il y a un autre truc qui est
vraiment génial en fait regardez là vous
voyez il continue à nettoyer c'est qu'en
fait les brosses elles viennent vraiment
sur le côté ça ça veut dire quoi en fait
que vos brosse elle soit vraiment sur le
côté ça vous permet regardez elle va en
fait elle va sécher dans un sens et dans
l'autre je le montre comme ça vous voyez
un peu tout le process dans un sens dans
l'autre mais le fait d'avoir la brosse
qui arriverait réellement sur le côté ça
permet que lorsque vous venez nettoyer
vous voyez comme ça à fleur de meuble et
ben ça vous nettoie jusqu'au bord donc
lorsque vous avez des plaintes vous
allez pas avoir une partie mort qui va
pas être nettoyée tout va être vraiment
nettoyé jusqu'au bout donc ça c'est
vachement bien ça c'est pareil une
innovation qui est roborock signé
roborock et que je trouve extrêmement
maligne donc voilà ça c'est cool je
regarde j'espère que tu feras une vidéo
si le son smoothie l'image était flou
c'est peut-être le débit mais
normalement on est pas mal en terme de
débit on est au salon on est au CES on
doit s'adapter aux conditions qu'on
retrouve ici mais ça fonctionne alors
j'ai quelques chiffres à vous donner ici
sur ce produit une recharge ça vous
permet d'avoir 20 cycles de nettoyage
hop là regardez on va venir se reposer
là
un cycle de nettoyage
40 minutes d'autonomie ça je vous l'ai
dit vous pouvez nettoyer
280 mètres carrés donc si vous avez une
très grosse maison en une seule charge
vous êtes vachement pénale le réservoir
de nettoyage c'est 900 ml et on a le
réservoir déchets qui a un petit peu
plus petit qui est de 770 ml on se parle
alors il n'est pas hyper hyper lourd on
se parle d'une bête qui fait 4,5 kg donc
vous inquiétez pas de toute façon on est
sur le sol donc le vous l'avez pas à
bout de bras vous le portez pas comme ça
et vous le déplacez c'est assez facile
on se parle d'un bruit maximum de 78
décibels et puis une puissance nominale
ça vous intéresse de 260 watts et c'est
un produit qui va être dispo mi-janvier
donc là il arrive il est présenté au CES
et il arrive vous allez pouvoir venir
l'acheter directement sur le site de
robot d'ailleurs je vous ai mis les
liens dans la description du live allez
jeter un petit coup d'oeil à 449 euros
pour venir nettoyer très facilement je
vous dis nettoyage sec nettoyage humide
avec la solution le détergent soit
vraiment vraiment pratique et puis une
fois de plus le fait de l'avoir dans
l'application roborock donc si vous avez
un combo par exemple je sais pas moi et
suite plus et que vous voulez prendre
votre Diab pro avec et bien vous avez
une seule application dans lequel vous
avez venu retrouver vos robots pilotés
très facilement et je trouve ça juste
hyper hyper canon donc voilà voilà pour
ce produit que j'aime beaucoup qui est
sympa pour la maison à vous de voir
après on n'a pas forcément besoin de
celui-là on peut préférer avoir un S8
celui-là il vachement bien parce que
vous pouvez venir directement vous
nettoyer mais si vous voulez vous pouvez
lancer que le S8 le dire viennent en tel
zone enfin bref on fait un peu comme on
veut il y a plein de solutions c'est
marrant de voir cette gamme qui évolue
sur Brooke qui est très complète et que
j'aime beaucoup alors maintenant on va
la regarder un peu d'un point de vue
purement technique comment ça fonctionne
on vient détailler regardez je vais vous
montrer déjà le système de brosse du
diap pro qu'on va retrouver là vous
allez comprendre comment ça marche en
fait c'est vraiment une découpe de votre
robot à l'intérieur de votre robot vous
savez ces brosses comme ça ça c'est à
l'avant et là c'est plus à l'arrière
donc là vous avez la grosse brosse ici
et là vous avez les deux petites brosses
qui vont jusqu'aux extrémités et qui
permettent vraiment de tout venir
nettoyer sur les côtés et lorsque vous
venez la nettoyer hop je passe en mode
clinique elle va venir tourner vous
allez voir en fait le sens de rotation
commence à marche donc là elle vient se
nettoyer en tournant dans un sens et
après elle va le faire dans l'autre sens
donc comme ça vous voyez la techno à
l'intérieur le robot est ouvert presque
donc je trouve que ce système là est
vraiment hyper marrant et ça fonctionne
donc là-dessus pas de souci donc vous
voyez on va vraiment comment ça
fonctionne à l'intérieur une fois de
plus on rentre dans les techno on est
une chaîne de techno alors bien
évidemment vous me direz monsieur gros
tu nous parle de robot oui parce que
sont des objets connectés pour la maison
vous avez de l'applicatif vous avez des
tonnes de capteurs mais en plus on va
venir regarder en profondeur et c'est ça
qui est cool de pouvoir faire ce live
ici en direct du CES c'est venir
vraiment vous montrer tout ça comment ça
marche donc ici on se parle du diète
plus je vais vous montrer viade pro
pardon et je vais vous montrer
maintenant comment ça se passe au niveau
des S8 alors ça c'est le doc du S8 pro
ultra regardez laissez-moi quelqu'un
laissez-moi vous montrer en fait ça
c'est tout le système de séchage c'est à
dire que une fois que vous avez posé
votre robot lui il va venir sécher donc
là vous avez de l'air qui va arriver
pour venir sécher toute la partie
arrière et là toute l'autre partie ici
donc là c'est la partie où vous avez
votre
serpillière ça vient le sécher sur toute
la longueur comme ça ça va éviter je
vous les ai une fois de plus d'avoir des
moisissures parce que si vous le séchez
déjà à froid c'est moi terrible pour les
odeurs comme ça pas de moisissures pas
d'odeur vous séchez à l'avant vous
séchez à l'arrière c'est très
fonctionnel et je trouve ça vraiment
vraiment extrêmement pratique donc une
fois de plus c'est toutes les
technologies qui sont intéressante ici
qu'on va chez roborock alors l'autre
truc qui est cool je vous disais tout à
l'heure entre le S8 et suite plus c'est
le même produit vous avez le vibreur
race mais c'est la première version
pourquoi parce que vous avez un seul
moteur donc ça vibre ça vibre très bien
mais avec le nouveau le S8 pro ultra non
là vous avez la version 2.1 c'est-à-dire
que vous avez deux moteurs si vous
regardez on les voit excusez-moi on les
voit les deux moteurs vous avez un
moteur là un autre moteur alors je sais
pas si vous avez bien vous en rendre
compte en vidéo vous ont mis des petites
pins pour voir réellement le type de
vibration donc vous allez pouvoir
différents niveaux donc là je suis dans
le mode le plus haut on on a quasiment
pas mais ça bouge à fond ça c'est la
vibration moyenne et puis là vous allez
la vibration plus sur le bas donc ça
vient effectivement adapté la vibration
en fonction des besoins que vous allez
avoir ça va dépendre une fois de plus de
votre sol ça va dépendre comment il est
donc ça c'est quand même hyper hyper
cool en même temps je regarde un peu
dans le dans le chat coucou comment ça
va je vous arrivez là garantie 2 ans en
plus c'est garantie 2 ans c'est la
garantie européenne de toute façon les
produits sont garantis de son
un petit peu on peut voir les robots
automatiques bon bah c'est relou
peut-être aller voir au niveau de la
qualité on a la délégation qui est là
maintenant regardez délégation de Séoul
qui est juste à côté de nous et qui
viennent visiter directement et puis là
il y a du monde on est sur un salon
c'est normal et là je vous montre le
système de brosse à l'intérieur vous
voyez vous le voyez vraiment tomber
l'intérieur d'un côté et de l'autre et
qui vient ramener toutes les
cochonneries ici donc on l'a dans ce
sens là et je vous le montre oh là
et ça marche comme ça donc vous voyez ça
c'est vachement pratique
pour venir effectivement récupérer à
toutes les cochonneries je vous dis ce
qui est très très cool c'est qu'avant
vous aviez une seule brosse alors si on
regarde comment marche ce robot vous
avez à l'avant toute une partie qui
tourne qui va ramener les déchets elles
arrivent ensuite ici ça aspire
l'aspiration mais en fait il y a pas que
l'aspiration qui marche parce que si
vous avez des fois des déchets un petit
peu durs à venir attraper et bien cette
nouvelle innovation avec ces deux
brosses en caoutchouc on va venir tout
ramener à l'intérieur et avec la
puissance d'aspiration de 6000 Pascal
enfin moi quand même du bois Sylvie
Pascal maximum donc vous voyez on a un
truc qui est très très cool durée de vie
on me demande alors on verra tard dans
la partie question réponse qu'on aura
tout à l'heure mais la durée de vie
c'est compliqué parce que le produit va
être annoncé mais moi j'ai des
aspirateurs roborock j'ai encore un S5
qui est fonctionnel à la maison et que
j'ai depuis 2018 tu crois depuis 2018 et
il marche très bien j'en ai eu des
tonnes et j'ai jamais eu pour l'instant
de panne je veux pas dire c'est pas
arrivé mais si un problème est bien vous
avez des garanties 2 ans mais pour moi
ce sont des robots qui fonctionnent bien
ils ont beaucoup que j'aime beaucoup que
j'utilise chez moi au quotidien on
reverra tout à l'heure la qualité est
bloquée à 720p peut-on changer pour tout
vous dire j'ai pas du tout la main
là-dessus si ça déconne c'est peut-être
qu'il y a un peu plus de monde qui
arrive ici et de toute façon il va
rester en replay et j'espère que la
qualité sera très bonne également si
vous voulez plus d'infos de toute façon
on reste je reste avec vous là jusqu'à
au moins 10h30 voilà pour toute cette
partie un peu technique alors on va
regarder parce que Robin effectivement
je me dis je voulais montrer tout à
l'heure c'est une marque qui existe
depuis de nombreuses années et on va
regarder quelques autres robots pour que
vous voyez un petit peu comment ça
marche regardez venez par ici je vais
vous montrer trois robots qui sont
intéressants alors chez le reborn je
vous le disais vous avez le Q5 plus là
par exemple vous voyez c'est un robot
qui est arrivé il y a il y a quelques
années alors le look a quand même
légèrement évolué je trouve un peu plus
fin aujourd'hui vous aviez hop là le
même
voilà le même système à l'intérieur sauf
que c'était un peu plus fat c'est un peu
dans l'histoire on voyage dans le temps
là alors tout écrit ici on se parle de
2700 Pascal d'aspiration de puissance
d'aspiration là où on est aujourd'hui à
6000 Pascal s'en va quand même du bois
on va pouvoir aspirer celui-là on voit
qu'on avait déjà le leader à l'époque et
puis on avait déjà un doc qui existait
pour pouvoir venir se vider donc là on
se parle effectivement d'un produit qui
était là avant enfin voyage un peu dans
le passé dans l'histoire de roborock
c'est le Q5 plus on annonce dans le
temps on avance avec le Q7 max plus on
voit que ça augmente au niveau de la
puissance d'aspiration tu as 4200 Pascal
on va pouvoir à la fois ici ça c'est
différent par rapport au Q5 plus et bien
venir aspirer mais également venir
nettoyer le sol avec la serpillière donc
ça c'est cool on avait toujours le
leader et puis ici le petit dog vous
voyez vous venez mettre vos déchets
comme ça ils viennent les récupérer
c'est pratique donc ça c'est vraiment
dans l'ADN de roborock et c'est quelque
chose pour trouver déjà avant et qui
continue vraiment à être fonctionnel et
qui est très sympa et puis on arrive
ensuite sur un autre modèle qui est
beaucoup plus récent qui l'a de l'année
dernière c'est le S7 max V ultra
en relation en partenariat avec brog
bien évidemment je suis payé vous
présenter ses produits mais c'est d'un
point de vue très personnel je vous le
dis une fois de plus ce sont des
produits qui sont fiables et que
j'utilise à la maison et là-dessus j'ai
absolument aucun problème donc voilà un
peu pour ce tour du stand maintenant je
voudrais qu'on passe un petit peu de
temps ensemble pour venir répondre à vos
questions pour venir discuter si vous
avez des questions sur les produits on
va pouvoir venir regarder ça ensemble on
va venir se poser il y a un petit peu de
monde qui s'installe il va falloir qu'on
qu'on dise à tous bon monde de partir
pour nous laisser la place on va
s'installer là-bas et on va venir
regarder ça c'est sûr
on se fait à la maison on dit aux gens
aller vous êtes mignons là maintenant on
se pose on est chez nous on est entre
nous les gars il faut partir comme ça on
est bien on fait le live ensemble donc
là on va passer allez à peu près 10
minutes à venir chatter ensemble
regarder répondre à vos questions parce
que je pense qu'il y en aura
quelques-unes fatalement et ça me paraît
normal et puis après on va faire gagner
ce nouvel pas nouveau aspirateur de
l'année dernière mais le concours avec
le S7 max V+ alors regardez on va venir
se poser là on est peinard on s'installe
on est bien ça va mon coco parce que
vous le voyez pas là il se met à genoux
devant moi avec le téléphone à la main
tu étais quoi c'est ça j'ai sur le sur
le live
pour lire vos petits messages est-ce que
tout va bien pour vous attends j'ai plus
rien je vais me reconnecter directement
ça c'est des fois les joueurs de la
connexion quand on est à l'étranger
comme ça je reviens ici sur le live
ça lag un peu est-ce que vous êtes
toujours là mes petits lapins hop là hop
là on revient juste ici donc là ça va
être une session de questions-réponses
pour pouvoir répondre à vos questions si
vous en avez sur ces différents produits
comprendre comment il fonctionne mais
pour l'instant j'ai l'impression que un
peu comme vous et bien la connexion
internet fait des siennes et je n'ai pas
accès tu vois les questions tant qu'il
s'affiche mon Léo directement à l'écran
donc ça veut dire que je suis toujours
là c'est juste moi ma tablette qui veut
plus trop qui veut plus trop en faire on
va y arriver tranquille ou on va venir
se reconnecter sinon je vais me
reconnecter au wifi parce que si je veux
pas vos questions ça va être compliqué
de dire vos réponses et chaque du
chargement vous voyez le salon a ouvert
il y a peu de temps tout le monde est là
et j'arrive plus à me connecter
bon et bien on va faire autrement sinon
je vais moi déjà peut-être vous donner
des informations si je vois qu'on n'y
arrive pas mais ça serait un peu dommage
parce que pour tout le concours ça veut
dire que on va pas pouvoir le faire
comme ça il va falloir le faire
différemment je me déconnecte je me
reconnecte je reviens en attendant si
vous avez des questions commencez déjà à
les je vais remonter un peu dans le fil
et je regarderai pour être en capacité
de vous répondre
allez je me reconnecte je reviens
rechercher non je m'en fiche on essaie
de se reconnecter directement voilà je
suis de retour je reviens là j'ai la pub
tout va bien tout est ok voilà j'ai les
messages ok alors on va regarder
est-ce qu'il y aura un S8 max vultra je
peux pas vous répondre parce que en fait
les produits qui viennent présenter ici
rodrome c'est les produits qui sont les
annonces ça veut pas dire dans l'année
vous n'aurez pas d'autres annonces mais
tout de suite malheureusement vous savez
c'est toujours un peu le le secret on me
demande la comparaison avec d'autres
marques c'est un live en partenariat
donc c'est compliqué de parler d'autres
marques pas en parler j'ai pas le droit
je voudrais bien mais j'ai pas le droit
mais ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
cette marque je l'adore elle est très
bonne et c'est pour moi un des leaders
sur le marché au niveau de l'aspiration
mobile possibilité de mettre du
détergent dans les robots automatique
alors normalement c'est pas recommandé
de le mettre directement dans le bac à
eau si vous prenez un petit réservoir
pour mettre du détergent dans les autres
vous en avez pas ça n'existe pas je sais
que ça existe
mais là vous en avez pas
protéips je vous le donne moi j'en mets
des fois un petit peu dans le réservoir
d'eau propre j'en mets un peu voilà
titre personnel c'est pas recommandé par
la marque mais moi je le fais dans mon
on peut venir le faire est-ce que ça va
est-ce que ça fait à faire que votre
produit est plus garanti peut-être pas
vous répondre et pour l'instant il y en
a pas en tout cas offre de lancement est
prévu pour les précommandes alors je
n'ai pas d'offre de lancement mais j'ai
uniquement les tarifs j'ai voulu donner
tout de suite comme ça vous verrez je
vous parle bien effectivement sur la
série S8 on dit à partir d'eux donc j'ai
pas les tailles de tous les tarifs c'est
le tarifs français à partir de 699 €, ça
veut dire que c'est le S8 pour le S8 pro
et pour la suite plus pardon et ensuite
pro ultra j'ai pas du tout les tarifs et
je sais pas s'il y aura les offres de
précommande une fois de plus allez jeter
un coup d’œil dans les liens que vous
êtes dans la description comme ça vous
verrez tout et vous saurez tout ça c'est
très cool l'Internet
US c'est vraiment pas terrible S7 plus
versus S8 plus je te dirai le S8 plus
fatalement parce que tu vas voir c'est
double brosse qui va te permettre de
ramener un peu plus une puissance
d'aspiration qui va être supérieure si
maintenant tu as pas besoin de 6000
Pascal de puissance le S8 le S7 plus
reste quand même très fonctionnel mais
juste vraiment deux gros points de
différence que tu vas avoir ça va être
la double brosse rotative pour me
ramener les cochonnes à l'intérieur et
une puissance d'aspiration
supplémentaire donc tu mets encore plus
de chance de ton côté pour venir tout
ramasser donc là dessus il y a
absolument pas de souci quel est
l'autonomie du S8 max
ultra alors je vais reprendre ma fiche
tech et je vais te dire au niveau de
l'autonomie je regarde je reviens dessus
j'ai peut-être la réponse en bas
alors tu me parles l'autonomie pour moi
c'est plus un vrai sujet je comprends ta
question j'ai pas la réponse sous les
yeux parce que pour moi il va venir se
recharger c'est à dire que même lorsque
ton robot il revient à sa base parce que
de toute façon il a besoin de se
recharger en eau propre et d'enlever de
l'eau sale ou de vider son bac il va
pouvoir se recharger c'est toutefois il
est il arrive plus donc cette question
là pour moi elle est plus trop
d'actualité il faut plus trop se poser
la question faut pas se prendre la tête
on te pose pas de question là-dessus
même si je comprends il y a légitime
j'hésite à prendre alors on parle de
notre marque mais non malheureusement là
j'ai
iPad y a-t-il combien y a-t-il
d'autonomies sur la journée une fois de
plus Jonathan te pose pas la question de
l'autonomie il va bien se recharger il
fera le taf quelle est la différence
entre la gamme et c'est la gamme Q la
gamme Q c'est la gamme milieu de gamme
d'ailleurs quand on aura un petit peu
moins pour poser des tarifs un peu moins
élevés la gamelle elle est beaucoup plus
cher on est quasiment 700 euros et on
peut monter on va monter à plus de 1000
euros bien évidemment la gamme Qora
tarif un peu plus maîtrisé on aura moins
de specs on aura moins de choses mais
fatalement on en aura un petit peu moins
mais c'est pas mais pour des gens qui
ont pas le budget à mettre 700 800000
balles dedans et bien de pouvoir avoir
un aspirateur connecté qui est très bon
très fonctionnel et extrêmement bien
maîtrisé quelle est la largeur des
brosses de Didier de plus ce n'est pas
l'info sur la largeur des brosses mais
ce que je peux te dire en tout cas les
brosses elles vont vraiment jusqu'au
bord et ça te permet de venir nettoyer
ton mur le long du mur le long de la
plinthe sans aucun problème je peux
regarder les
les spécifications techniques si tu veux
du produit mais très honnêtement je ne
suis pas du tout convaincu d'avoir la
largeur alors laisse-moi regarder je
vais là on se parle
du djihad pro j'ai la fiche tech j'ai
peut-être des dimensions de produits
mais pas convaincu non multi rouleau
j'ai pas la j'ai pas la dimension
j'ai plein de trucs tu vois j'en ai des
infos mais ça je l'ai pas tu m'as posé
une colle et merde ça je l'ai pas ok on
va continuer la double brosse doit être
pas mal j'avoue c'est très très pratique
il y a des poils de chiens ou ça bloque
non ça bloque pas ça bloque pas si ton
chien a pas de 10 mètres tu vois qu'ils
vont venir s'enrouler autour il y a
absolument aucun problème tu peux dire
nettoyer les poils de chien les poils de
chat sans aucun problème beaucoup de
choses il y a pas de souci là-dessus il
y a pas du tout de problème enfin pour
le si tout le tram mais également pour
les autres il y a aucun problème l'eau
est-elle
électrolysé je n'ai pas cette
information pour te dire où elle reçoit
51 je serai pas de te répondre y a-t-il
une grande différence entre le S7 et le
S8 oui ce que je disais tout à l'heure
en fait entre le S7 et le S8 la grosse
différence c'est la puissance
d'inspiration où on était je crois 5100
Pascal sur le S7 et là où on monte à
6000 Pascal donc beaucoup plus de
puissance aspiration la double brosse
rotative et si tu vas sur le pro ultra
tu en plus le double moteur au niveau de
la vibration donc ça permettra de
nettoyer
plus en profondeur en fait voilà la
principale différence pour venir
retrouver ici entre entre ces robots
principales différences quelle
différence entre S7 pro et le S7 ultra
alors on est sur les S8 donc on est plus
réellement sur les sur les 7 c'est les
gammes d'avant il y avait trois offres
autonomie dans un autre live tout à
l'heure bon ben voilà peut-être ça j'ai
un S5 Max qui me conseilles de changer
ou d'attendre encore un an alors moi
Gabriel
si ton S5 max fonctionne encore et s'il
te vient s'il te convient garde-le je
pense qu'il faut pas changer les
produits tout le temps il faut faire
attention à changer trop régulièrement
c'est ces produits si ta maison est
propre s'il te convient bien et si tu
n'as pas des problèmes de nettoyage
concerne le ça évitera vraiment parce
qu'il faut pas surconsommer et une fois
de plus je présente des produits tech et
je le redis je prends des produits parce
que j'adore ça mais si vous avez des
produits fonctionnels que ce soit des
téléphones des tablettes des aspirateurs
conserver les temps qui fonctionne tant
qu'ils font le taf et tant que vous
voyez que ça va bien avec votre maison
est propre notamment ici au niveau des
aspirateurs robots quel est l'âge de
brosse je ne l'ai pas
y a t-il une caméra sur le site il n'y a
pas de caméra il y a un leader en fait
le leader c'est un laser qui va venir
cartographier et qui verra donc on va
pas venir faire des photos des objets
ici il y a pas de caméra et puis plus de
caméra sur la suite versus le S7 il y a
pas de caméra il y a le leader qui
fonctionne et ça fonctionne très très
bien quels sont les nouveautés de
l'application avec ce S8 c'est
l'application que vous avez déjà l'année
dernière j'ai pas de nouvelles
applications ici la nouveauté que vous
allez retrouver c'est c'est lié à vos
produits donc si vous avez la dernière
version de l'application et bien vous
aurez toutes les dernières
fonctionnalités liées à votre produit
que vous avez et si vous venez acheter
forcément ce nouveau produit et bien
vous aurez les nouvelles fonctionnalités
liées mais l'application reste sur le
principe exactement la même
j'ai acheté le S7 c'est une dinguerie
une fois de plus je te le confirme
j'adore le doc
ultra du S8 est-il compatible sur le S7
max V je ne pense pas je pense que
vraiment ils sont totalement spécifiques
parce que les évolutions au niveau du
nettoyage essayer ça donc je ne te
conseille pas alors après ça reste très
technique comme point et une fois de
plus c'est pas ces informations là mais
je te conseille pas moi de venir prendre
un dock d'un produit pour le mettre sur
un autre parce que si jamais tu as des
Sud tu pourras payer cher mieux vaut
contacter directement roborock le SAV
voir avec eux là-dessus j'ai les
batteries tiennent avec le temps j'ai
jamais constaté de problèmes au niveau
de l'autonomie alors une fois de plus
c'est là où peut-être je ne le vois pas
c'est à dire que quand il a besoin
d'aller recharger il le fait il repart
est-ce qu'il va le faire plus souvent
sur honnêtement j'ai pas mesuré ça donc
c'est très compliqué de venir te
répondre là dessus
[Musique]
il est malheureusement
la serpillière fait des traces en
parquet le S8 est-il plus performant
là-dessus alors hyper transport avec toi
Hervé je suis sur un salon je vois des
démos là-bas je ne vois pas également là
c'est des démos d'aspiration j'ai pas
des démos de lavage je pense ça dépend
de ta serpillière normalement les
serpillière neuve elles font pas de
traces est-ce que tu dois peut-être que
tu as essayé de prendre ta serpillière
avec le détergent de bien assécher et
ensuite de recommencer alors moi sur les
robots j'ai pas le dernier à la maison
mais j'ai la dernière génération j'ai un
set j'ai pas de j'ai pas mais je vois
j'ai déjà eu avant ce genre de choses et
je pense que ça mène ça serpillière qui
est pas propre faut vraiment peut-être
venir la laver et tu verras à ce
moment-là
pourquoi est-ce que la cartographie sur
le
Q7 max plus et plus avancé 3D que sur le
S7 plus
normalement sur les c'est plus d'avoir
un leader en plus ce qui fait que tu as
une cartographie 3D c'est ton leader en
fait qui va venir cartographier tes
pièces maintenant pourquoi est-ce que
sur le S7 plus
ça aurait pas te répondre comme ça tout
de suite je t'avoue j'ai plus les infos
sur les nouveaux produits sur les
anciens là directement avec moi et grâce
à toi j'ai pris une trottinette ah tu
vois ben je tire quelque chose c'est
très très cool voilà donc on va encore
passer un petit peu de temps si vous
avez des questions venez je vais essayer
de vous filer quelques infos
supplémentaires également sur cet
produit qui peuvent être potentiellement
intéressantes pour vous
je vous ai dit au niveau des aspirateurs
à suite et suite plus et suite pour
ultra la cartographie les nogozone les
routines vous pouvez l'envoyer sur une
zone en particulier à la reconnaissance
des objets grâce au leader on peut venir
laver aspire en même temps sur le pro
ultra on peut venir que laver si on veut
pas aspirer tandis que sur les autres on
aura forcément et bien la respiration
qui va marcher en même temps ça c'est un
peu aussi une grosse différence entre le
est-ce que tu expliques plus et le S8
pro ultra qui est un aspirateur qui
fabriquait quand même différemment donc
ça c'est chouette s'il passe sur des
moquettes comme vos anciennes génération
on vient relever la partie serpillière
pour éviter de de frotter une sorte sur
une moquette ou un tapis ça ne servirait
absolument rien sur le diète pro et bien
on a également
euh
17000 Pascal depuis sans aspiration
c'est complètement dingue des produits
que j'adore alors est-ce que c'est
quelques infos à vous donner en Europe
le le S8 S8 plus S8 pro ultra arriveront
en mars avril le 10 août au mois de
janvier est-ce qu'on peut acheter un S8
sans le doc d'un oui parce que les
fourni sont le doc
je regarde un petit peu si j'ai d'autres
infos à venir
vous donner on les a en noir et en blanc
sur chaque modèle ça aussi c'est c'est
super on se parle des S ainsi S8 S8 plus
ultra qui fonctionne très très bien
je crois que je vous ai à peu près tout
dit
[Musique]
une date de sortie ça je voulais dit
tout à l'heure l'obsolescence programmée
c'est après combien de temps il y en a
pas alors je ne suis pas dans le secret
des marques mais ici on en parle pas je
pense pas qui en est l'idée c'est pas ça
c'est d'avoir des produits durables dans
le temps moi j'ai des produits
aujourd'hui une fois de plus de roborock
depuis des années j'ai encore un S5 qui
marche très bien et qui fonctionne très
bien donc il y a pas de souci oui les
cadeaux on va y arriver on a Mouda qui
arrive tous salut à toi roboc prévoirait
en France il y a fatalement savait que
j'ai géré en France oui alors les prix
j'ai voulu leur donner parce que ce sont
pas les prix de tous les produits j'ai
le tarif alors pour le diète pro j'ai le
tarif effectivement il est à 449 euros
puis dispo au mois de janvier et puis
pour les S8 j'ai le tarif à partir de ça
veut dire sur le S8 on est à 699 euros
on se parle d'un lancement mars avril ça
ne saurait tarder on en reparlera parce
que c'est des produits que je testerai
que j'aime beaucoup donc on regardera ça
également dans quelques temps pour le S8
le S8 plus S8 pro ultra je n'ai pas
aujourd'hui les tarifs mais fatalement
ils vont être un peu plus plus élevé
donc on en reparlera donc une fois tous
j'ai mis les liens dans la description
vous pouvez cliquer dessus et vous serez
alerté lorsque les produits sortiront et
vous aurez toutes les infos là-dessus
donc vous pouvez y aller il y a
absolument aucun problème voilà qu'en
est-il du séchage de la serpillière du
S8 alors sur le S8 et le S8 plus il n'y
a pas de séchage de serpillière il y en
a pas si vous voulez un séchage de
serpillière il faut aller sur le S8 pro
ultra sur les autres il y en a pas c'est
à dire que ils vont sécher naturellement
voilà j'ai vu que le train était à 1500
peut-être j'ai pas du tout cette cette
info je pourrais pas dire Mickaël voilà
donc maintenant je voudrais qu'on passe
un petit peu de temps sur le concours
parce que je vous le disais tout à
l'heure ça s'est très très chouette ça
va mon coco je devrais ajouter les
vaillant il est là il est heureux on va
faire gagner deux produits Robot rock S7
max V plus c'est pas le dernier mais
c'est un produit qui est juste topissime
croyez-moi mais là il y a donc deux
produits à venir gagner alors fatalement
je vais vous poser des questions qui
sont en lien directement avec ce qu'on a
regardé pendant quasiment 7 heures de
live
donc je vais vous poser les questions et
ce qu'on va faire c'est que la première
personne qui va me donner
la bonne réponse repartira avec et
repartira avec les cadeaux alors il y a
deux questions il faudrait être le plus
rapide le ou la plus rapide alors pour
vérifier que c'est bien vous jolie tout
de suite je donne les règles directement
je vous demanderai de m'envoyer j'ai
votre pseudo qui va s'afficher moi je
vais faire des captures d'écran comme ça
je les aurai envoyé moi bien votre
capture d'écran de votre compte et vous
m'en verrez par email sur mon mail hello
he llo@mieu greu avec trois aires grr.fr
vous m'en verrez directement la capture
d'écran de votre compte directement avec
votre émoticône et c'est ça comme ça je
saurais que chez vous et on vous enverra
enfin reborant que vous enverra à vos
cadeaux très rapidement alors est-ce que
vous êtes prêt Hervé ma c'est trop
mignon merci beaucoup Hervé merci pour
ce que tu fais tu es top c'est très
gentil de ta part merci allez on va y
aller vous êtes prêts la première
question je la remets sur le chat et je
vais voir directement qui donne bonne
réponse le premier ou la première
personne à donner la bonne réponse
repart avec un aspirateur de roborock on
se parle ici du roborock S7 max V+
j'espère que vous avez suivi parce que
c'est vraiment une question qui porte
uniquement uniquement sur les
spécifications techniques des nouveaux
produits de roborock alors on y va la
question la première je l'ai beaucoup
répété beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
télé tension soyez le plus rapide de la
plus rapide quelle est la puissance
d'aspiration du roborock et suite à une
plus et suite pro
ultra la puissance d'aspiration en
Pascal le premier en là Benjamin ok
Benjamin 6000 Pascal bravo Benjamin je
te fais une petite capture d'écran comme
ça je sais que c'est toi qui a gagné
Benjamin bravo félicitations 6000 Pascal
tout ça vous est arrivé Aurel est arrivé
deuxième je suis d'accord del soluce non
5100 c'était sur le modèle d'avant voilà
c'est très compliqué je reconnais il y a
toutes les bonnes réponses c'est
Benjamin qui a gagné on peut féliciter
Benjamin Bruman alors Benjamin j'ai ta
photo je toi qui tu es envoie-moi bien
une capture d'écran de ton compte
Youtube pour bien être sûr que que c'est
toi qui est pas des petits malins qui
veulent se faire passer pour toi et
enfin moi bien par mail à hello he2lo en
entier le monsieur en entier Roger avec
3h grr.fr tu m'envoies par email et on
te ferai pas venir ton robot c'est robot
là Benjamin tu pourras pas gagner deux
fois donc c'est pas la peine de
reparticiper félicitations à toi tous
autres vous avez encore une chance pour
participer pour la deuxième question dès
que c'était différé ouais je sais c'est
compliqué comme ça il faut ça peut créer
de la frustration mais on en refera des
cadeaux il y aura d'autres choses à
gagner vous inquiétez pas alors je vous
le donne tout de suite on va regarder
maintenant pour la deuxième question je
me la remets en tête comme ça je me mets
sur le chat direct
là ça va être un peu plus dur on va se
parler du diap pro la question je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure donc ça va
laisser vraiment plus de chances à ceux
qui n'ont pas autant les 6000 Pascal je
l'ai dit un paquet de fois autant là je
l'ai dit une fois donc si vous avez été
très attentif attentif et bien vous
allez pouvoir peut-être avoir une bonne
réponse attention combien de cycles de
nettoyage peut-on faire avec une seule
recharge du diable pro attention on y va
j'attends la bonne réponse 17 non c'est
pas la puissance c'est pas du tout les
Pascal c'est combien de cycles de
recherche comment faire ah on a
Guillaume de la bonne réponse 20 bravo à
Guillaume c'était un peu plus pointu un
peu plus dur c'est Guillaume Catino
Guillaume de la même manière on savait
un petit peu moins c'est un peu du
pifomètre 160 Gabriel non pas du tout 22
40 19 40 voyez là c'était vraiment
fallait savoir Christelle tu avais la
bonne réponse il y avait quelques
petites bonnes réponses vous avez
vraiment suivi c'est très très cool
voilà non bah c'est Guillaume qui a
gagné félicitations à Guillaume donc on
a d'un côté Guillaume Catineau qui a
gagné ici
on se parle bien les aspirateurs
roborock on se parle bien je donne la
réf vous avez gagné tous les deux
Guillaume et puis excusez-moi j'ai la
tête qui est va exploser parce que on
est là depuis un petit moment et que
beaucoup d'infos et puis Benjamin
Guillaume et Benjamin vous avez gagné
tous les deux un robot rock S7 max V
plus félicitations c'est très très
chouette et puis alors il nous reste
cinq minutes à venir passer ensemble je
tiens vraiment à vous remercier c'est
une première de venir faire un live à
l'étranger au CES comme ça sur le site
de roborock alors je vous redonne les
infos un peu essentielles tu vas réussir
à te lever mon Léo là ouais tu vas aller
on se relève on se refait un petit tour
très rapide pour revoir les produits
vous allez pouvoir
claquer il y a eu un petit crack au
niveau du jeans alors regardez ça se
passe par ici on a d'un côté juste
derrière moi S8 S8 plus S8 au max des
produits qui vont arriver très
prochainement on en reparlera sur la
chaîne donc soyez attentifs ça va
arriver restez connecté on en reparle
ensemble et on va pouvoir on va voir ça
il y a également le diable pro qui va
arriver à très prochainement qui arrive
au mois de janvier et lui et qui est
hyper canon le diable Pro vous allez
pouvoir retrouver une fois de plus tous
les liens sont dans la description ça
c'est très très cool vous allez pouvoir
retrouver puis il y a eu beaucoup
d'innovations il y a plein d'autres
produits rock c'est une très belle
histoire avec beaucoup d'innovation de
l'aspiration de la puissance et puis
voilà c'est chouette et c'est une marque
que j'aime beaucoup donc merci à
roborock de m'avoir donné l'opportunité
de faire ce live une première ici au CES
à Las Vegas alors on pense il est
quelque chose comme
19h26 ici il est 10h26 du matin la
journée ne fait que commencer on est sur
le deuxième jour du CES on va aller
faire le tour un peu partout on va
filmer des choses on va vous ramener
plein de souvenirs beaucoup de contenus
courts vous allez pouvoir retrouver bien
évidemment sur Youtube en short il y en
aura également sur Tik Tok sur Instagram
sur Facebook on est également sur
Facebook un peu partout et puis bien
évidemment des vidéos qui vont arriver
également qui sont en train de se monter
en train de se faire qui arriveront un
peu plus tard sur Youtube on est au
deuxième jour du CES voilà jusqu'à
dimanche soir retour en France prévu la
semaine prochaine avec plein de
nouveautés plein de choses et puis un
peu les tendances qui vont arriver sur
l'année 2023 donc je voulais vous
remercier profondément tous tous et tous
d'avoir été là hâte de voir tout récap
sur le ces merci Hervé félicitations
avengy bravo vous êtes tous très mignons
je vous embrasse passe une très belle
soirée merci d'avoir été présente sur ce
live directement ici sur stand de
roborock au CES on se parle très bientôt
dans le broc et puis bien évidemment
continuer à me suivre sur les différents
réseaux parce que il y a plein d'infos
j'ai filmé des choses absolument Léo a
filmé et j'ai parlé des choses
absolument incroyables des choses de
dingue au ces innovations totalement
surprenante des choses des pouvoirs
racheter d'autres noms c'est des choses
qui arrivent beaucoup plus tard mais qui
sont vraiment génial donc on reste
connecté on regarde ça je vous fais un
gros bisou cool merci pour ton boulot
Suez merci Christophe c'est trop mignon
euh Caroline nous dit j'ai un souci avec
mon SS je peux vous écrire Caroline je
serai pas en capacité de te répondre
mais contact directement tu as toutes
les informations sur le SAV sur leur
site pour avoir des informations comme
ça nature technique c'était très sympa
merci gros merci à toi d'avoir été
présent félicitations à tous d'avoir été
là ciao merci merci à vous d'avoir été
pendant ce live on se retrouve très
bientôt bien évidemment sur tous les
réseaux et puis on va continuer nous de
se balader directement au service ici à
Las Vegas voilà je me retourner puis
j'appuie sur le bouton pour accrocher
voilà tu vois le petit bouton pour
accrocher le live mon coco tu le vois ou
pas il y a un petit bouton non pas
regarder allez je vous embrasse prenez
soin de vous puis moi j'appuie sur le
bouton voilà je me retourne je vais
trouver un petit bouton ici voilà hop
des bisous bisous bisous bisous bisous